morning everybody it's truly my pleasure
to be here today to briefly discuss my
favorite topic my telus international
family as well as to share with you a
little bit about how Google has helped
to enable our success by a show of hands
how many of you has ever solved a
rubik's cube i thought would be
everybody in this room actually maybe
not jim did you know that the world
record for the fastest rubik's cube
solve is for dot 9 04 seconds and then
it's held by a 14 year old boy from
Kentucky what I find most fascinating
about that no not that he's from
Kentucky but rather the actual number of
permutations that are possible 43
quintillion that's a 43 followed by 18
zeroes and all based on the decisions
one makes on how to twist and turn the
54 elements of the cube 42 years after
its invention I believe this fascinating
cube is a great analogy for the growth
and success of telus International as
you just heard briefly in Parkers kind
introduction our company has grown
exponentially since our inception in
2005 starting with just 1,500 team
members one location in Manila providing
support in English only I'm proud to say
that 11 years later we have what I
believe to be the best team in the
business process outsourcing industry
are 25,000 team members serve some of
the world's most iconic brands across
high-tech retail gaming ecommerce
healthcare travel finance and telecom
from state-of-the-art facilities in
North America Central America Europe and
Asia our recent 1 billion dollar
enterprise value is predicated upon our
proven formula
we carefully select and invest in
companies whose values are aligned with
ours who have teams that welcome and
celebrate diversity in leadership that
leads by example and in people who
respect others while we've only made
three acquisitions one in each of Asia
Central America and Eastern Europe and
each of those businesses had fewer than
1500 team members at the time of our
original investment our real challenge
was harmonizing these similar but
distinct corporate cultures each of
those teams took a different approach to
recruitment man onboarding to
communication and collaboration to
performance management and reporting
utilizing diverse operating models tool
systems and technologies to ensure we
realize the requisite synergies from
acquiring and integrating these
disparate groups and to support our
aspirational growth whilst consistently
delivering a best-in-class client and
team member experience we needed to
think and act differently after all
according to the literature seventy
percent of acquisitions actually destroy
shareholder value so my story isn't
about where Telus International is today
it's about how we arrived here how we
overcame these challenges and most
importantly how we plan to execute upon
our ambitious goal to more than double
the size of our business in the next
five years or less and this is where
Google and their incomparable suite of
business tools come into play so let's
imagine that each one of the nine
squares on each side of the Rubik's Cube
represent a different business function
that the teams and operations in each of
our delivery centers brought to the
table functions like HR practices
recruitment training learning
development sales marketing
communications payroll reporting which
all culminated enabling our team to
execute upon more than 175 million
customer interactions we manage annually
via voice chat email and social media
the thought of how many different tools
forums processes and how disconnected we
might be as an organization was
overwhelming remember the 43 quintillion
permutations I mentioned earlier so we
had to quickly and effectively align our
teams on a global scale and we found the
perfect partner with which to do so in
Google deploying Google cloud-based
technology enabled us the standardized
how we did business across our entire
enterprise and in the process helped us
to collaborate and innovate promoted
agile thinking and actually increased
our team member engagement so how you
may ask well we know that our team
members are our greatest competitive
advantage which is why we've cultivated
a unique caring culture that's driving
industry-leading engagement attrition
rates and scores that are better than
the competition which have in turn led
to better performance and increased
top-line client growth we call this the
culture value chain and as confirmed by
frost & sullivan we can now directly
correlate our unique corporate culture
with our industry-leading performance so
constant communication and collaboration
amongst our team members around the
world it's critical historically teams
attempting to collaborate across time
zones would inevitably encounter issues
with timeliness and version control of
documents leveraging Google Drive and
hangouts our teams easily edit documents
presentations simultaneously and in real
time they can quickly book a video
conference from their desk inspiring
spirited teamwork and continuous
collaboration and innovation
additionally our move to add thousands
of google chrome boxes to our limited
number of cisco telepresence units has
made video conferencing more readily
available and approachable enabling us
the cost effectively gather our team
members for training sessions
recognition events customer meetings
business reviews and even board meetings
also by deploying Google Chromebooks to
our team leaders on the floor in our
contact centers they now provide
real-time feedback and on-the-spot
coaching to help their team members grow
and succeed in their roles the ROI has
been impressive with near instantaneous
improvements in our clients key metrics
and happier more engaged team members
who recognize our investment in their
professional development and they stay
with us longer to
their careers finally our pace of growth
makes business intelligence even more
critical to our decision-making process
leveraging Google scripts and sheets we
developed and deployed a unique
cloud-based bi platform which in real
time aggregates operational data from
multiple sources like a CD time
reporting CRM and quality applications
as a result we now have standardized
operational reporting across the globe
that provides deeper insights for us and
our clients even with our over 100
clients and terabytes of data our
frontline team members could instantly
assess performance and take corrective
action to help us proactively deliver on
our customers first promise so as you
can see our partnership with Google has
enabled us to essentially speak the same
language in so many different ways which
is I think all the more remarkable
accomplishment given that our agents
speak over 35 of them on a daily basis
with our customers and we're only just
getting started as we've just got two
new pilot programs underway leveraging
the power of Google's machine learning
capabilities to take a revolutionary
approach to real-time fraud
identification and PCI support as well
as contact reduction and automation when
we're aligned as a team and as an
organization we have the white space we
need to be agile and innovative to focus
on growing our business and creating
value for our clients and importantly to
do what is at the heart of our caring
culture to give back to the citizens and
communities where our team members live
work and raise their families well I'm
so very very proud of what our team has
already accomplished in working to make
the world a better place having
contributed 336 million dollars to
charitable and not-for-profit
organizations and more importantly
provided almost 7 million hours of
volunteer service to local communities
building schools and homes for example
there is still so much more that needs
to be done I could not be more excited
by what's ahead for telus international
and with Google by our side as our
trusted technology partner I have no
doubt we will achieve our ambitious
growth targets
may perhaps take just a little bit more
than the 49 seconds however thank you
all for your time and attention today I
welcome the opportunity to answer your
questions if any during the break